Ted Hart: When I was 13 years old, I lost my hearing when I got the
mumps.  As you can imagine, this makes it very difficult to
communicate with people.  When I met my future wife she was
able to communicate with me only by spelling out letters on
my hand.  A month later, we met again, and I found out that
she had taught herself the alphabet.  This was a successful
strategy because we’ve been married now for
19 years.
Will Lewis:  Last fall Ted had come to my office to tell me
about an idea that he had for adapting Skype Translator to a
scenario that would actually be useful to him.  Ted, being
deaf, can't make calls over Skype.  But with Skype
Translator, because it produces transcripts, he could
actually read the response back from someone.  So we sat
down and talked about it for a little bit and there were
some pieces missing in Skype Translator.  So we needed
actually do something to make it more appropriate for that
scenario.
COMPUTER:  Ted Hart is requesting an automatically translated
call.
Ted Hart:  I usually need to have an ASL interpreter for my
meetings at work.  That means that meetings have to be
planned in advance and sometimes this isn't always possible.
It doesn't replace an ASL interpreter but it gives me a lot
of other options if one can't be reached at the last minute.
Will Lewis:  These features were really impactful for Ted in his
work life.  What really hit me was the realization that
there was a big impact on his personal life.
Ted Hart:  I realized that using Skype Translator I could call my
wife directly for the first time.  There are relay services that
you can use, but they are inconvenient and require time to
initiate the call.  With Skype Translator, I just read the
transcript and I understand what she is saying.  It's really
cool that 24 years after she learned sign language to enter
my world, I can take a more full step into hers.
Jenny Lay-Flurrie:  So I was sitting back thinking about this and
looking at it and realizing the impact that this could have
for me, for people here at Microsoft, and for our customers,
for people with deafness, with hard of hearing, all over the
world, technology has that power.  It can empower people to
do things and make things easier.  It's available now.
Download it.  Give it a try.  And help us to make this a
better and better product.